[Music]
Dancing with the Stars squeaked out a
narrow victory over the voice last night
in the ratings and in case you missed it
well we learned to another interesting
tidbit about Blakey wins romance
then you took a song that's actually on
my make out playlist that's cute when I
told you I knew that song well now we
know the song win a Blake smoochy to
hunters heartfelt singing one when's
heart and she saved him in the knockout
round
that leaves Johnny gates on the brink of
elimination he sat down with ETL lines
Katie crowds for a Facebook live chat
and took questions from fans Susan says
Johnny you're so talented is a talented
gent like you oh man well Susan Susan I
actually am single at the moment and
I've been kind of focused on the music
right now but Susan feel free to add me
on Facebook and here's something you
might not know about Johnny yeah Blake
go way back well sort of I lived in
Nashville for like 7 years and Blake and
me were on the same record label they
would have all the artists take a big
group picture together and I somehow
ended up next to blade but this cool
photo of Blake he's got his arm wrapped
around me so um I need to get that to
Blake I need to somehow I think one can
help you out there maybe I can text it
to go on and be like yo she's number not
yeah but I need to work on that yeah
don't talk like that part out there
[Music]
you